[Music]
and blame millennial news
oh that always happens every time
submitted by
calculator games oh remember those
hewlett packards that used to be so
expensive and you had to get them for
trig and then now
texas instruments
i never even took trigonometry
i just went to geology geology
the mathematical study of rocks
absolutely good good good good
only the geometry please build rocket
ships that's what will happen to the
human race once a nuclear war happens
dude we'll go right back to geology bro
i got a c in geometry but i aced uh
physical
physics calculus calculation it says ap
physics ap calculus
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
saying i'm drunk i didn't go that route
you know which way i went i went the
statistics sway oh
yeah you know how there's the two routes
yeah but the statistics one ends
that's all i needed for them but there's
like different kinds of statistics
in high school it was like uh algebra
build that and it was like uh
geometry statistics statistics
statistics
different kinds of things research
statistics
the dick stick sticks millennials are
now being blamed for the tragic decline
of american cheese
dude i love [ __ ] cheese i will blame
millennials for everything
[ __ ] is it good for vegans yo they get
blamed for everything now it was the
last generation got blamed for
everything now it's millennials yeah
it's their turn
you know what it is though they're
bringing back real cheese that's why i
will say this though that is the reason
why
exactly that's a hundred percent people
are so [ __ ] snobby with their [ __ ]
food now dude yeah they are they're like
american cheese isn't real cheese then
what the [ __ ] is it [ __ ] it's just
cheese
you need to use [ __ ] american cheese
and burgers
yeah damn straight straight up you're
god damn right thank you
dude but i'll take a smoking gouda if
you have a but see
even that you put smokey good into a
[ __ ] in-n-out burger get that [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of my mind that's not the same
yeah no i don't that's like an umami
burger type of thing
they each have their place like i don't
i'm not going to like spit on them
american cheese in my burgers you'll
never have like swiss in that [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] about swiss dude
[ __ ] swiss you can't even you can't even
taste you can't even taste yours hate
swiss cheese
what i've been saying this is my whole
life a little bitter it's like a little
bitter taste
i can't really taste it you can't i used
to get it because i thought it was diet
cheese because it has holes in it
it actually is it actually has the less
least amount of calories
it does right i was right but it was
it's really simple math but
that's the only part of math i'm good at
is getting a [ __ ]
hole in your [ __ ] lately though i've
actually been getting into cheese
yeah i never used to like cheese oh
really yeah no but then lately
like like feta cheese that shit's
[ __ ] good
that's good bro [ __ ] smoky cheddar
like the real [ __ ]
you can get me into brie cheese that's
just good oh that is yeah oh brief's
good check this out dude
next time you go [ __ ] camping yeah or
we all go camping yeah
breathe [ __ ] will wrap it up in foil
throw it in the fire
[ __ ] fondue really yes and you do
apples you put apples in there
let's go camping i'm in for that and
everybody's just farting up a [ __ ]
storm
but it doesn't matter that's fine it's
the same thing yeah why is somebody
lactose it's because they're lactose
intolerant yeah i was farting up a
[ __ ] storm but i would take
those little smoky sausages
and then we would dip it into that
[ __ ] brief fondue that sounds great
just have a heart attack on the way home
it was just meat and cheese meat and
cheese meat and cheese
you know what though the fake cheese
melts so good it does
like that real cheesy melt like velveeta
yeah with the nachos yeah
what about those little triangles you
know what i'm talking about the train
oh i talk about the like wax cowbell
those
he's cooler than you he wears cool
jackets he's way more legit together
i said it too i'm sorry string
chief way cooler than he's becoming more
knowledgeable about
food and like all this other stuff yeah
but you can't have nacho cheese with
[ __ ] pretentious cheese
you think they [ __ ] nachos in europe
yeah but they put [ __ ] lobster on
that
it needs to be like when in rome type of
thing so if you're on a dodger game it's
got to be like that fake ass
cheese if you're at a french restaurant
no mcdonald's like they're bending too
oh what
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
whatever the demand is in the tree
mcdonald's now
just know your [ __ ] mcdonald's no who
you know your clientele
we just want that we just want the
[ __ ] big mac the quarter pounder and
the fries man look i don't like any of
your [ __ ] but just stay wherever you are
nobody wants an artisan
sandwich from a mcdonald's unbelievable
they're salty
yeah they are pretty salty what are they
doing they're doing is that they're they
are replacing it for one that's
preservative free so american cheese one
that's like preservative free and then
wendy's is now offering asiago
and w's canada only has real chocolate
but the preservative is what makes it
taste so good
yeah panera bread has replaced american
cheese with
four cheese blend font but you should
like
replace it just have it as another
option that's it yeah
what they're saying like just all in
general like sales
for american cheese have declined
dramatically
and so it's like not even worse it's a
supply demand thing yeah i will say this
since the get-go so when i had like you
know like all that [ __ ] cheese
because i love cheese right but then
they were like flipping out the
the [ __ ] so funny it's such a funny
general thing to say
i just love it yeah i love cheese i love
chicken cheese
they [ __ ] started switching out they
start switching out like in the
restaurants
like with the regular burger it's
cheddar i don't want cheddar like i
want to taste the cheese you can't taste
it as for me my personal opinion yeah
when you have the
they're not strong enough to overpower
that beef and [ __ ] flavor i want to
i want to taste that cheese can't taste
it but it's not you don't want to taste
cheese you want to taste this fake
flavor that's not in real cheese yeah
yeah it just makes it
whatever professor i just want to taste
the people no i'm just trying to
i'm trying to figure it out i'm trying
to figure out like what exactly he's
missing
i think american cheese goes really well
with hamburgers hands down
it's because of the cheddar that they're
replacing it with is not real good
cheddar
because that's have to say there's some
sharp ass yeah i like a cheddar on a
burger too
that's cool but it did what's sharp
cheddar it's like it's like
it's like a little bit sour salty yeah
see all of you are professors
it's like a strong i don't care about
cheese
i liked goat cheese i'm right there with
you sheep and goat
[ __ ] yeah i grew up on that [ __ ] soft
cheeses what was that cheese oh and brie
what was that cheese that we had at that
store yeah that's feta cheese
that was good i like it it's made out of
sheep that was the best feta cheese i've
ever had
do you know way more [ __ ] like we had a
they just took us
all over europe man they were like you
want to try you want to you want me to
[ __ ] take you through the world and
we're like oh yes please
and they just started shaving all this
different cheddar and [ __ ] all kinds
of what was this i heard if you're
lactose intolerant
feta cheese is okay for you i don't know
if i'm lactose
but check this out though i can't
usually do dairy products
but no eczema breakout i could [ __ ]
eat that [ __ ] all day
right next to our uh downtown la office
there's like
two things that i want artificial cheese
on obviously hamburgers and the philly
cheesesteaks
oh three things philly cheese steaks i
love cheese whipped cream
cheese whiz i don't think i don't think
i've ever had a legit philly cheesesteak
before
go to booze out in case go downtown have
you been to kohl's oh
i think booze is way better they have a
speakeasy in the back too oh that's cool
kind of cool i want the one with the
cheese was on and it's all like legit
and like [ __ ] sliced alone
yeah like it's like whipped cream but
there's cheese instead yeah but you've
never had it like
i've seen it like in the goofy movie and
stuff but i've never it's not as like
whippy as that it's usually like a
solid line of cheese but yeah it's not a
good philly cheesesteak place unless
there's a picture of sylvester stallone
like like shaking the store's manager
like the store manager's hanging like
out of it
where am i i love that cheese whiz
[ __ ] philly cheese steak [ __ ] this is
so [ __ ] good it sounds
bam man we're getting hungry huh yup
yeah
can you tell a lot of um fake [ __ ]
is like also not on a decline too
because
millennials are more food conscious and
aware of like
preservatives and all kinds of unhealthy
sharp these nuts [ __ ]
yeah i mean they will if you keep eating
it true yeah
just from the inside out because yeah
and so
say it again david for those numbers
baby preserve these nuts
yeah they're also saying like the price
uh per pound
of this american cheese is
going lower and lower oh great yeah you
know
make it cheaper for us i mean it's
already started pretty cheap though
right
you like those craft american singles oh
yeah that's what a hamburger
i love it i like it [ __ ] i hate it i
mean not that i hate it i'll eat it but
i just it
bugs me i guess that's not my teeth i
love that that's a snack for later
i actually don't like that dude remember
uh
lunchables dude yeah yeah like with the
little bologna and the cheese
yeah and the crackers so that was
american cheese
no it's cheddar isn't it cheddar cheese
you're right you're right
american cheese is the slices i was just
thinking it was definitely fake cheese
cheese yeah they don't have blood
no it's like it's like the slices it's
like yeah it's not even cheese
in subway the like first kind that they
put on there it's like the pizza the
little
little lunchables pizza yeah it was like
a different species though yeah the
mozzarella and it's just like really
uniform shreds
oh yeah like nachos you're so really
nachos you need the [ __ ] queso dude
that [ __ ] nacho queso [ __ ] oh
you know what it is though it's that way
you're eating pizza like you
it wasn't very good it wasn't like great
it was just like
oh i'm having pizza for lunch awesome do
you remember the pizza
uh string cheeses where they had the
pizza sauce in the middle of the strings
what oh wait i do remember that oh that
was bomb because i didn't like cheese
but i love pizza and those tasted like
pizza
you peel them and it's just like it
tastes like you made that uh
wait didn't they have like a they have
yeah the guy that had like the hair
[ __ ] i forgot the name of that dude
but like he had a mascot for like cheese
it was like string head something i
don't know it just it was
one of those all the burger king kids
had names too i don't [ __ ] remember
that
burger king kids you remember the burger
king kids no they were they're all like
had future
[ __ ] space weapons and [ __ ] and like
goggles yeah that's true
oh yeah one of them wrote a flaming
flying skateboard
what the [ __ ] i don't even know what
you're saying it was pretty metal
damn i don't [ __ ] remember anything
it was before they brought back all the
mascots
so like the mascot you know like the
king and and then burger king the burger
king
that's the only mascot i know and then
jack in the box
you know brought back their mascot the
jack jack gone for a while
yeah yeah it was it was gone for a long
time and they brought them back in like
the
90s or the two or later box disappeared
completely
and almost shut down because of that uh
i don't know there's something with the
meat
oh you're talking about the mad cow
scare
i don't know what it was but a lot of
the restaurants shut down dude they have
a double
bacon western cheeseburger there's not a
single vegetable in there at all and i
love it
that's the carl junior one right it's
just bake it's meat
cheese bacon meat cheese fried onion
ring barbecue sauce
is onion and vegetable like you deep
fried it but that's a vegetable i don't
know it's good though that's a vegetable
onion fries i mean onion rings earrings
that's when you ring it though
when you fry it though it's no longer
really a vegetable what about fried
zucchini though
yo i [ __ ] with their [ __ ] tacos
though jack-in-the-box tacos potatoes
are vegetables it's
tofu i don't give a [ __ ] what it is yeah
i heard it that's not tofu
i love fast food [ __ ] i could talk about
fast food forever my favorite is taco
bell me too
is amazing del taco cheesy gordita
crunch
yes sir thank you god bless you
chalupa dude chalupa's good yeah okay
do you guys remember this taco bell song
nobody remembers it i swear i feel like
i'm crazy
okay it goes chorito
and oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah nobody
remembers this
commercial it was like a big thing yeah
and then it disappeared they took the
entry
off the menu and then nobody knows what
i'm talking about anymore i'm like no
the commercial had the song
and they're like that was never a thing
i wish that david did not give you that
i know i
i wish that you were crazy joke i wish
that in the video
yeah but i would feel truly crazy if
david didn't know what happened
i know the guy that voiced that
chihuahua why did they get rid of that
that was the best you know the guy that
voiced that guy yeah
[Music]